let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads
explode let me be clear before this
podcast begins
we are loud proud and
do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not
liberty you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah
the smell of freedom of speech this is
the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] him
[Music]
good afternoon everybody welcome to the
tony michaels podcast
this is episode one the very first one
and i did not plan
to have episode one on impeachment day
but god what a great day
it may be they're voting right now
as we speak they're voting on the floor
of the house
i've been watching it uh pretty much or
listening to it all day
and we're gonna talk about impeachment
here today
uh to to be quite honest with you i had
a completely different show planned
probably
and here we are after january 6 the
events that happened
we are talking about impeachment a
second time around
almost one year after the first
impeachment
and there's a lot to unpack uh we're
gonna spend some time unpacking a little
bit of it today
i know you guys appreciate the
commentary that i have
on political events and current news
but um i want to go over first exactly
what this podcast is going to be and i
want to introduce you guys to somebody
uh and as we go along here we're going
to do some different things with this
podcast not only are we going to talk
about political issues but we're going
to try to get some other guests on here
to give us
their idea and their background on the
political issues and current events
i want to hear from other people and
their
what their feelings are on things that
are going on
and there's a hell of a lot going on
here recently isn't there holy [ __ ]
so the first thing i want to do is
introduce you guys to sam
sam's going to be helping me out with
this podcast
sam is a mom of two and
she's doing mom things today so she's
actually in the car
uh currently there's sam right there
say hi sam hi guys
so there's sam she's gonna be helping us
out you're probably gonna hear from sam
a few times
um but uh today it's mainly just gonna
be me because
you know all right sam thank you very
much
okay so let's talk about what this
podcast is going to be
we're going to talk about political
issues social issues and we're going to
do it in a progressive type of way
and a [ __ ] you type of way as you guys
know my favorite phrase is
[ __ ] um and it's kind of a protest term
so it's a protest to all those who you
want to protest
it's an easy way a very easy way
to protest an idea a group of people a
certain person
and to show your protest loud and proud
[ __ ] em
so you're probably gonna hear the word
[ __ ] you're gonna hear a lot of curse
words
but we're gonna talk about a lot of
different issues and we're probably
going to
really commentate on a lot of different
people
but today there is something in
particular that we need to comment on
um and it's the impeachment of donald
trump so before we started
sam actually brought up a really good
simple question and it's not a dumb
question it's not
it's actually at the crux of what
they're that what they've been debating
all day long
and the republicans have been clamoring
about it the
democrats have been throwing it down and
stepping on it
the idea that we're going to impeach a
president
just a week just over a week
before he leaves office
so why are we gonna do this why in the
actual
[ __ ] does it make sense
to to hold donald trump to account of
what he did on january
6th well other than the fact that he's a
dangerous [ __ ]
and there's no telling what this guy
will do in the last seven days
setting that aside if we
let donald trump get away with this if
we
let him get away with trying to attempt
a coup
which as evidence comes out it seems
more and more and more
likely that there's not just going to be
uh
white supremacist groups like the proud
boys and other
groups that are associated with nazis
but it seems as if
it's possible that people are alleging
that there are members of congress that
participated in the planning
of this event and we'll know more about
that
in the coming weeks and months uh and
i'm sure
i'll have a plenty a lot to say about
those [ __ ]
but why impeach donald trump and hold
him account
and the reason why is if we don't hold
this president to account
it doesn't matter if it's republican or
democrat from now on
if they if if a president really
believes
that as long as he has a a a big enough
base that are violent enough
to perform a coup then by god why not
try it
i mean donald trump tried it and there
wasn't a [ __ ] thing that happened to
him
so why should i not try it why shouldn't
i give it a shot
to stay in power and who would say that
it wouldn't be just after a first term
it could be after a second term that we
have this problem
so this isn't just to punish donald
trump
this is to protect our constitution
which those insurrect
insurrectionist treasonous bastards
were trying to overturn on january 6.
what did they think was going to happen
let's just let's just surmise for a
second that we were
that we were going to uh pretend like
they always do
we're going to pretend like they were
successful
and they would have overturned the
election what did they think donald
trump was going to do with the
constitution after that
did they think he was just going to love
the document and think oh this
thing's fantastic alls i did was have to
overturn it and bam on the president
still
did we really think that after his
second term he would
peacefully transfer power after we let
him
after we let him try and and maybe
successfully succeed
to commit a coup is that what is that
what these people
thought and it brings us to
the biggest issue here and it's been
playing out all day
on the floor of the house where
these folks are and by folks i mean uh
uh
fascist nazi republicans are standing on
the floor
uh basically basically saying
that oh joe biden's gonna be inaugurated
in seven days why are we even
here what could possibly be the purpose
of us impeaching the president
if in seven days he's gone
well it's nice for you to admit it now
that there is
there was a violent insurrection on the
capitol
where the [ __ ] were you sons of [ __ ]
on december 14th
i remember moscow mitch mcconnell coming
to the senate floor
and getting getting excoriated for it
for coming out and saying it's over
it's done joe biden won [ __ ]
you ain't got a shot that thing on the
sixth that's gonna happen
that thing ceremonial and from that
point on the president united states
encourage these people to go to
washington encourage these people to
fight and that's why
we are at the moment that we're at an
impeachment and that's why right now
as we speak right here they are voting
on the floor of the house to impeach
donald trump
for the second time for inciting
insurrection
which is is a easy way of saying
treason i have a couple different clips
i want to play for you guys today
uh it it makes me think you know what
the events of today have made me think
back
on several tick tock videos that i've
either done or listened to
and i have several i have one that i i
especially want you to listen to
um real quick you guys really like this
it gets spread around
tik tok a lot um it's actually it's one
of my videos
um i i think it's a good message and i
want to talk about it on the other side
so let's talk about our democracy for a
minute reason why i'm so confident in
the fabric of our republic
is because the fascists are concerned
that it's rigged against them here's a
real big [ __ ] secret
it is rigged against you you [ __ ]
dummies
the constitution was not set up or
written to give
your [ __ ] crystal fascist
authoritarian
[ __ ] oxygen you [ __ ] trump flag
waving freedom [ __ ]
don't know what freedom liberty or
rights even are freedom to oppress the
rights of other people
it's not liberty you [ __ ] shit-eating
[ __ ]
and that's why it seems like the
constitution is against you
and you're so [ __ ] pissed off so let
me give you a nickel's worth of free
advice either go get a history book on
fascism and then participate in this
democracy
or crawl back in your little snowflake
bubble where you belong
it really is not [ __ ] rocket science
gomer pyle
[ __ ] them so that video right there is
one that everyone likes everyone
continues to spread around and do it um
it's actually my
most dueted video and i believe it's
because of one phrase
inside of that video and the phrase goes
like this
and remember this because this is very
important to what is going on right now
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people
is not liberty the freedom to oppress
the rights of other people is not
liberty and liberty is what we strive
for in this country
and freedom and rights are the vehicle
that provide us that liberty and the
constitution
grants us those freedoms and rights but
you do not have the freedom to oppress
the rights of other people
that's not the [ __ ] point that's not
and i know i've said this before that
it feels like our democracy is a threat
and and and folks i actually think it's
very strong
the fabric of our republic is
strong very strong
it worked it worked beautifully
was it was there violence was there
death
of course there was that was this these
people's mission
was to cause chaos to try to attempt a
coup
but they would not overthrow the
document that actually
grants us the right to stand here
and rebut them and rebut their leader
with an impeachment
because folks what's happening is not
the tearing of our democracy
what is happening what is happening
to our country is that we are hearing
the ripping
of the seams of the republican party and
we're seeing it live and in person today
when you have members of the republican
caucus coming to the floor
in the debate and claire declaring
that they will vote for impeachment of
donald trump one of them
the the most prominent one of them
is liz cheney and that is very very
significant
very significant and her statement
gets right at the heart of it and i
believe what we're feeling in this
country
as the republican party tears themselves
apart
is this
equality to some with privilege
feels like oppression equality
to some of the privilege feels like
oppression it is
white grievance through and through and
through and regardless of the truth
that that their country is not being
taken away from them
it's it's what they feel and it's wrong
and it will take time to heal these
wounds but right now we need
justice and we need to make sure that
these people are held to account
rather it be the president of the united
states rather be the person who
who crashed through the window whether
it be the person who bludgeoned a police
officer over the head and killed him
rather be the person that stormed into
nancy pelosi office thinking that they
were going to kidnap her
or whatever whatever their plan was
or rather it's a congress person that
may have actually assisted these people
these people we need to hold them to
account
and that is the most important part of
this healing process
which brings me to their little oh we
need unity
i thought you were talking about unity
well there is unity in this country
folks
there is unity do you know where the
unity lies
there are liberal progressive socialist
commie democrats banding
with corporate one percent america here
to protect the constitution in our way
of life
that is the unity
and we are unifying against fascism
and when and when people get out in
front of a microphone and
say well i thought you wanted unity
when we should unite don't impeach unite
here's a big secret about that person
they're the fascist
that's what they are that's why they're
saying what they're saying
let's not be coy about it that's how
this is going to work
so i have another sound i want to play
for you it's not my sound it's not my
video it is a tick tock that i found
and i want to talk to you about it on
the other side as well
because this one really gets to the
heart of what
my tick tock today was about uh because
i've been talking a lot about privilege
and a lot of my tick tocks because i
think that's what we're seeing
is the oppression
of the privileged they're lashing out
so let's let's watch this video
and i'll talk about it on the other side
this is a target
where you buy condoms this is the
capital
our seat of government it protects the
rights that
folks fought and died for
and there is no equivalency
these are people who have been
slaughtered
fighting so they will not get murdered
and here they're protesting real
actions so there is no equivalency
the time will come to heal divisions
but now we need to consider justice
cause this is protest and this is
treason so there can
be no equivalency
so let's talk about equivalency because
they've been
badgering this issue on the floor the
republicans the fascists
talking about how the black lives matter
protest
the protest for civil rights
the call for police not to kill
black people in this country
is somehow equivalent to the
overthrowing
of the government itself
what in the actual [ __ ] and where the
[ __ ]
are you people even getting off to to
equivilate these two things
so you're going to tell me that it is
the same
[ __ ] thing to protest a free and fair
election the results
of that free and fair election
with the protest so that
black people don't get killed by police
officers
that's the equivalency
we're going to take and by the way
because they keep saying all
burning buildings and and burning police
precincts
well i happen to believe reports
and arrest of bugaloo boys
who participated in the burning of
buildings
so let's not get the facts construed
it wasn't black lives matter that burned
buildings to the ground
they were asking for justice they were
asking not to be
killed but these people at the capitol
these people at the capitol were telling
the rest of the country that it didn't
matter that the state certified the vote
because they didn't get their way
so let's be honest folks we're dealing
with snowflakes we're dealing with
snowflakes they're whining and crying
we watched them as they got arrested in
airports
couldn't get on planes marched out of
their houses
we've seen the mug shots of them and
we're going to see many many many
many many more yesterday uh
the us attorney of washington dc
gave a press conference and he talked
about this and he
told he told the public we have 160
charges and it's the tip of the iceberg
folks and some of these charges
and some of these uh uh people are going
to be
indicted not only with trespassing
that's a
start but it looks like sedition
insurrection possibly treason
and some of those sentences could carry
prison terms up to 20 years
so i would imagine and and he also
stated that
it they're not going to stop they're
going to underturn
overturn every single rock that they
possibly can
to find what actually went on and who
helped plan this
and that it's not just the people at
that were at the capitol storming the
capital
breaking things and trying to kill
people and kidnap people and trying to
overturn the government of the united
states it's also going to be those out
there
that were trying to plan it
and i would suspect over the next
several months we find out that
it was mainly white supremacist groups
that were in charge
of organizing and convincing and duping
these people into going to washington
and inciting them to storm the capital
that they had the white right i mean the
right
excuse me i didn't mean to throw white
in front of that word
they had the privilege of treason well
guess what
they didn't have it they don't have it
and donald trump does not have the
privilege to avoid impeachment
if what he does is impeachable even if
it's only a week away from
his term ending and we shouldn't grant
that right not just to him but any
president that would commit this act
to try to overturn the constitution
of the united states
and we should continue to fight
for this constitution and vote
that's how you fight vote
vote vote vote
the last time we fought fascism on a
large scale
on this planet
fascism lost
it didn't go away and it won't go away
folks it's an idea
it's an idea and these people
they may live with it may perpetuate it
for a long long
long time
but the only way the only way
to prevent it from taking over our
government
the only way is to make sure that we do
not
give it oxygen
that's it we have to vote against
fascism
so thank you for joining me today on
the very first episode of the tony
michaels podcast
i do want to give you an opportunity to
support us
and i appreciate all your support out
there everyone that follows me on tick
tock
likes my videos all the people that
joined in today and all the people that
have watched this
after the fact but i do want to give you
a chance to support us because
it just does cost a little bit of money
to produce this show
so i'm gonna give you an opportunity to
look at a few
products that we have over on our merch
store maybe buy a shirt or something all
that money
will go towards the podcast to help us
keep producing this and we're going to
keep doing this every week
right now we're going to do it
wednesdays at three o'clock if you guys
for about 30 minutes if you guys keep
listening and keep watching and
demanding more and more content well
we'll just go longer
and if that's not enough we'll just do
two days a week we'll do three days a
week
do four days a week and maybe five days
we'll see we'll see it depends on how
long we go
but we'll keep going so let me show you
let me show you how you can support us
[Music]
[Music]
so thanks for all your support run on
over there and get you a [ __ ] sticker
or something right our [ __ ] shirt
everyone loves it i say that
[ __ ] um everyone loves that
that's something i've said for a long
time i actually it's that's a shortened
version that you guys get on tick tock
because tic toc is only 60 seconds long
so
i can't say the full version of [ __ ]
but since it's the very first episode of
the podcast and i got plenty of time i
got all the time that i want
i might as well give you the elongated
version it's [ __ ] in the ass
[ __ ] em so that's and and you can also
do the whole uh
[ __ ] trump and anyone who looks like
trump
[ __ ] em and then you can add anyone's
name into that little phrase
anybody and one in particular today that
i'd like to give a shout out to
is [ __ ] louie gohmert and anyone who
looks like louie gohmert
[ __ ] em so thanks for joining us on
episode one
and come back next week for more
political commentary
from the tony michaels i appreciate all
you guys i really do
uh i love the support thanks for all the
comments on tick tock
i hope you'll keep joining me and you
guys will come back
and come back and come back
so thanks a lot guys oh yeah and before
i forget
one last thing [ __ ] em
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news
no rules no boundaries i think we've
made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon
in the meantime follow tony on social
media
at the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them